c'était l'affluence des grands jours à
montigny le bretonneux pour le premier
week-end des grandes vacances c'était en
sable attire les foules
le savent déjà ce que j'adore la mer
donc c'est un avant goût des vacances et
ensuite l'ambiance c'est plein
d'animations donc à mesure c'est
désagréable
des fois après tu fais la queue sur nuit
on m'a appris des voyages vers le jeu
wayne watts est un grand toboggan après
s'il sait que la boue c'est c'était trop
bien on a trouvé que c'était une très
bonne idée de passer du temps à l'été en
sable et tous les ans et la fidl le fait
que ce soit voilà aussi bien organisé
c'est vrai qu'à pas mal d'activités je
regardais justement le petit le petit
programme donc c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment enfin c'est plaisant voilà
d'avoir autant d'activités toboggans
jeux d'eau lapin géant et surtout la
plage de sable lésigny montain se sont
donnés rendez-vous accueilli par les
huit encadrants
ça permet aux personnes qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de partir en vacance de
pouvoir s'adonner à des activités
estivales avoir un petit air de vacances
ça permet aussi de préparer ses vacances
quand on les a tardivement et de venir
régulièrement soirée parce qu'on est
camou vert jusqu'à 20 heures
les week-ends face à l'affluence des
années précédentes plus de 33000
personnes en 2018
la commune a fait le choix de réserver
l'entrée à ses administrés plus de 600
imminente ont inauguré le premier jour
des vacances
une affluence confirmé le dimanche